WITHOUT JAMAL MURRAY IT'S
INTERESTING THAT JOEL
AND THAT IS TRUE
>> Jim: WELL SPEAKINGG DENVER.
OH, NO, COFFEY TO THE CUP,P,E A
>> Brian: WE'RE SEEING CUP AND
COFFEY CLEARS IT AWAY FOR THE
CLIPPERS.
IN TO
AMIR FROM THE WING TO THE L L
INSTANT BREW FOR THE CLIPPERS.
BACK THE OTHER C.
THEY HAVE TO FINISH IT HERE WITH
>> Brian: SECOND AS
>> Jim: THE CHALLENGE WITH
CLIPPERS.
HE IS ONE OF MY FAVORITE WATCHES
FREEDOM TO PASS.
I KNOW YOU WANT TO STEP BACK A
THE WAY T JEFF GREEN.S IN HEALT
SAFE FOR THE
MORRIS WITH TEN TO SHOOT,rian: .
DOWN THE MIDDLE OF THE FLOOR.
HE CAN FLY.
HE SWOOPS F THE HORN
AND KNOCKS IT DOWN.JOKIC.
RISES AND INTO THE
O
BE ONE GAME UNDER .500 AT THE
MIDWAY13.
TERANCE MANN GOES RIGHT INSIDE
AND LAYS IT IN!
FOR DENVER.
GORDON, OFF THE  JUMP PERT
DOESN'T TOUCH IRON.
SEXY.
AND HEL.B.'S, AND HE'S
ABLE TO ABSBS
SHOOTAROUND.
HIS PLAN IS TO
THE LEAD SWELLS BACK TO 20. TO .
MEANWHILE MARCUS MORRIS SR.
WAWA TRIGGER ON THE
FOR THREE.
BOUNCES OVER JAMAL,
RIM, COUNT IT AND A FOUL!
!
AND THE THE LANE AGAIN, OH
AND LAYS IT HOME!
OKLAHOMA CITY.
MANN A THE LANE, TO THE
RIM AND IN!
OH, MY!
JOKIC  TO THE CUP, OH, HE
>> Brian: ONE TOE SPIN AT THE
BASELINE A PAIR OF
DEFENDERS LIKE THEY WERE SALOON
DO FOR THREE, OH HE THRIVES IN S
LIKE THIS, BOU GORDON.. FOR THR.
AND THE LEAD!
OH, MY!
MENTS LIKE THIS, THE FADY
IS GOOD.
>> Jim: I MEANN
FROM THE FIELD IN THE FRAME.
REGGIE, OH H D, IN TO AARON
GORDON.HERE?
>> Jim: BOOM, BOOM.
>> Brian: AMIR FOR THREE! 1-2
PUNCH FOR DENVER A A SENIOR.